un saludo de tres dedos por si al sin el
símbolo de la lucha de los manifestantes
por la democracia cientos de personas
acudieron el jueves al funeral de la
joven de 19 años en mandalay la
bailarina y campeona de taekwondo fue
asesinada el miércoles de un disparo en
la cabeza por las fuerzas de seguridad
durante las protestas esta foto de
momentos previos a la muerte se ha hecho
viral y el eslogan todo irá bien sobre
su camiseta se ha convertido en un grito
de protesta para los manifestantes
contra los militares
el miércoles fue el día más sangriento
hasta ahora desde el golpe militar a
principios de febrero un hito sin
precedentes que llevó a las naciones
unidas- a endurecer su posicionamiento
les advertí de que los estados miembros
y el consejo de seguridad tomarían
medidas más serias y su respuesta fue
que estamos acostumbrados a las
sanciones y ya sobrevivimos esas
sanciones en el pasado
los testimonios de los presentes afirman
que las fuerzas de seguridad abrieron
fuego contra la multitud con balas de
goma y munición real sin aviso previo en
varias ciudades dos adolescentes de 14 y
17 años se encontraban entre los muertos
según sevilla children por el momento
las condenas internacionales han sido
ignoradas por los militares diplomáticos
afirman que el consejo de seguridad de
la onu se reunirá el viernes para
debatir sobre esta crisis ya se plantean
sanciones por parte de los países
occidentales incluidos eeuu